a guest on msnbc who is on al sharpton's
show thought that it would be clever
to compare american pro-lifers
to suicide bombers
this is a matter of civil rights
having the right to an abortion is a
constitutional right it's grounded in
the right to privacy that is within the
constitution and i find it
really interesting that
part of this argument is an argument
about you know the rights and abortion
is not explicitly listed in the
constitution but you know what neither
is the right to bear arms that the way
that we interpret that law is the
interpretation of a constitutional
provision the second amendment and this
we are interpreting another con we're
interpreting another constitutional
provision yet that's we're not applying
that same logic to this situation
i'm not sure where this lady went to law
school but i think she might be
misinterpretating the constitution here
because she's saying yes no i mean maybe
the right to an abortion yeah sure you
can't find it in the constitution but
you can't find the right to bear keep
and bear arms either
except you can
it's in the second amendment and it's
spelled out in exactly those words
she
i don't even know what she's trying to
say
but the constitution is quite clear that
the right of the people to keep and bear
arms shall not be infringed meanwhile as
she acknowledges there is no right to an
abortion she's saying that the right to
an abortion is implied by the general
right to privacy that also doesn't exist
in the constitution show me the general
right to privacy where is that
we'll get to that in one second first
though i've got to talk about truly one
of my favorite companies in this country
paint your life paint your life is
unbelievable i was extremely skeptical
of it at first and so what i did was i
ordered one for my stepbrother i ordered
one as a gift okay paint your life you
submit a photo or multiple photos to
paint your life they will choose a
world-class artist to create a painting
for you i like the oil paintings it can
be sort of any size you want it can be
different different types of painting
and
you can even get it framed
and i thought it was going to be crappy
art that's what i thought okay because
it's so inexpensive it's so easy they
work with you every step of the way i
got this painting back it is beautiful
it's so beautiful that i then almost
immediately ordered one for myself i
have it hanging in my living room i've
got another one getting ready to go
delivery is super fast you can get your
portrait in as little as two weeks i
think this is one of the most impressive
companies around today
makes a great present for a loved one
makes a great present for yourself right
now you have got to go check out
paintyourlife.com no risk you don't love
the final painting your money's refunded
guaranteed for a limited time get 20 off
your painting 20 off and free shipping
just text the word michael to 64 000.
that is michael mich ael to sixty four
thousand text michael to sixty four
thousand paint your life celebrate the
moments that matter most term supply
available paint your life dot com slash
terms that's michael text it to 64 000.
then she goes on to make her final point
we're all like suicide bombers what it
reminds me of quite honestly is a
suicide bomber someone who feels like
they have the right and the moral duty
to mess up somebody else's life for the
greater good
so the pro-lifers we're like suicide
bombers because you know what a suicide
bomber does is a suicide bomber believes
that he has the right
and the duty to mess up someone else's
life for what they can perceive to be
the greater good
like an abortionist
like
you're saying
to be like a suicide bomber you have to
think that you have the right to mess up
someone's life so what is messing up
someone's life is messing up someone's
life
i guess preventing someone from killing
someone else if that person wants to
kill someone else i guess you know in a
way you could call that messing up
someone's life but
i'm gonna give you two scenarios one is
you prevent someone from killing another
person
and that is inconvenient for that other
person so what is
a greater example of messing up
someone's life that
or
killing someone
which which messes up someone's life
more
i think
the latter probably does
so this woman
not the brightest bulb in the pack
on msnbc with al sharpton also
not the sharpest tool in the shed
he doesn't get any respect no
r-e-s-p-i-c-t
al sharpton show some r-e-s-p-i-c-t
nor should this woman because the
argument she is making
is actually undercutting the point that
she she is
trying and failing to make
[Music]
[Music]
you